- Welcome to a conversation with history.
I'm Harry Kreisler
of the Institute of International Studies.
Our guest today is E.J. Dionne Jr.,
who is a senior fellow at
the Brookings Institution
and a columnist for the Washington Post.
He's the author of several books,
including Why Americans Hate Politics,
They Only Look Dead: Why Progressives
Will Dominate the Next Political Era,
and he's the editor of two books,
one with John J. DiIulio,
What's God Got To Do With
the American Experiment,
and most recently, a
book with William Crystal
called Bush vs. Gore: The
Court Cases and the Commentary.
E.J., welcome to Berkeley.
- Good to be here.
- Where were you born and raised?
- I was actually born
in a hospital in Boston
but I was raised in a place called
Fall River, Massachusetts, which is
a factory town about 15
miles south of Boston.
A lot of people go through my hometown
on the way to Cape Cod.
I love my hometown, I've
spent time up there.
My mom died a few years
back, I get up a little less.
It was a very political town.
A friend of mine once said
that there were three kinds
of people in Fall River,
people running for office,
people getting ready to run for office,
and people recovering
from running for office.
And I think you just sort of,
you got interested in politics
just by breathing the air.
- And how did your parents
shape your character,
do you think, in retrospect?
- Well, in a lot of different ways.
I mean, my mom was a teacher
and librarian most of her life.
She worked and retired at age 75.
And so, you know, books were,
I got to love books and
book learning through her.
My dad was a dentist who
loved newspapers and politics.
I mean I think I'm
totally a creature of my,
and happily so, a
creature of my upbringing.
My dad would get four Sunday newspapers
and he loved to argue politics.
My whole family loved to argue politics.
And so, in fact my dad argued,
my dad and I argued all the time
about A, politics and B,
why the Red Sox were losing.
- And in these arguments,
you often would take
positions that you might not have held,
but you were forced to
think about them and argue.
- Right, my dad had a wonderful idea,
which I hope I, you
know, sort of stick to,
which is, he thought it was a good thing
for kids to argue with their parents.
He thought it was a good thing,
they sorta sharpen your mind
and you sorta have to come to terms
with whatever you're arguing about.
So he would, my dad was a conservative,
but I always say he was a
compassionate conservative
before compassionate
conservatism was cool.
But he was also very independent-minded.
So he was against the
Vietnam War before I was,
which is very much the reverse
of what happened with a
lot of people at that time.
But he would usually take a position
well to the right of his own
and I would often take a
position to the left of my own,
and we would go at it.
And the lesson I learned from that,
and also from my, my dad's
family was a very large family
and that was a very
political time with Vietnam
and every family event
was a political argument,
and it was a politically diverse family.
And I guess what it taught me
is you can disagree with someone
and love them all the same,
that there's something, argument
itself is not a bad thing.
To me, civility, which is a
very popular word these days,
civility is not about being mushy
or not disagreeing on anything
or pretending that you have,
you know, consensus when it doesn't exist.
Civility is respecting the
person you disagree with.
And that's what's in short supply,
not assuming that the
person you disagree with
is sort of Al Capone or Hitler
or some character like that.
- And a key in this, I guess,
is also listening, actually, to the other.
With the respect goes the notion
that you actually listen
to what their saying,
and that you might possibly learn
from what the other side is saying.
- There's a philosopher
at Boston University
called Glen Tinder, and
he has a wonderful idea.
He says that what we need to create
is what he called the attentive society.
And he says the attentive society
is a place where we all acknowledge
that we need to give and receive
help on the road to truth.
And I think that's, I love that idea.
And also, Christopher Lash talked about
argument in a similar way, where he said,
you know, if you really
engage in argument,
you're actually putting
your own views at risk,
because you really have
to enter imaginatively
into the ideas of the other person.
And that's a lot more fun
than just yelling at somebody, I think.
- You said in one interview,
"I grew up believing that
politics was not only a good thing
"and an important thing,
but that it was fun."
- Right.
I mean, again, this is a product
of Massachusetts and
Fall River in particular.
Mary McGrory, the great columnist,
once said that every baby
born in Massachusetts
is born with a campaign manager's gene.
And I think there's a
lot of truth to that.
You know, people were very involved,
from the sort of lowest
level to the highest level.
They cared a lot about, you know,
we have great mayor's races
and city council races.
You know, it was, for a kid who,
this isn't always the
best model for politics,
but it is part of it.
There's a kinda competition in politics
as there is in sports.
And when you look at it it's actually
an interesting endeavor
that people are engaged in.
And then, I also think, you know,
you're a product of where you came from,
you're also the product of
the time you grew up in.
And I grew up in a time when
politics was held in very
high esteem in the country.
Eisenhower was president.
I was born in 1952 and was eight years old
when John Kennedy was elected.
And what you had there were two models,
different kinds of leadership,
but people whom Americans respected.
And we were coming up
sorta the Depression period
and World War II, where people felt,
you know, government and, if you will,
collective endeavor actually
accomplished good things.
And so, you know, that's my view
and I'm gonna stick with it.
And it shaped me and it sorta pains me
that, you know, when I look at
sorta the experience kids
have now of politics,
you know, we went through a long period
of disengagement, scandal and the like,
and it creates a wholly
different attitude,
for completely understandable reasons,
toward public endeavor.
- Let's talk about that in a minute,
but one element I wanna
add here is your education.
You went to Harvard.
And how did that add a layer?
And then you went on to become
a Rhodes Scholar in England.
So I'm just curious how this civic culture
and this citizenship way of modality
were influenced by your education.
If I can link the two, I mean,
one of the good things
about going to Harvard
was that it was close to my hometown,
it was about 50 miles away.
And at the time, I was
there from '69 to '73,
and this was a time of a
lot of antiwar activity.
And there was a wonderful
man in my hometown
who's very very important to me,
he was like a second father,
my dad died when I was 16,
and his name was Burt Yaffe and he ran
for Congress in 1970
as an antiwar Democrat.
I always say we ran 50,000 votes
better than the previous Democrat,
the bad news is that we
lost by 25,000 votes.
But he was a fabulous guy.
And I used to bring
down lots of my friends
to work on various political
campaigns in Fall River,
and that was a time when
there were a lot of people
who were Marxists or
claiming to be Marxists,
and I always told them it was about time
they actually met the working class
that they love to talk about so much,
and I said, you know,
you'll actually like them.
And you know, so for me it was,
I didn't feel, when I went up there,
you know, sometimes people go to college
and, you know, again, for
understandable reasons,
kinda separate from their hometown,
and for me it was really good to,
I had enough distance,
it was 50 miles away,
and yet it was close enough
that I felt the two came together.
You know, some of it, there are sort of
several different things
that I think of now
that I took away from that
experience, academically.
One was, I got interested in sorta
political philosophy and social theory.
One of the bests courses I will ever take
was a debate between Michael Walzer,
the great sort of social democratic
or democratic socialist
political philosopher,
and Robert Nozick, the
libertarian political philosopher.
And they gave a class called
capitalism and socialism.
And to watch these guys hammer out,
I mean, first of all, for a kid to see
what philosophical argument is about
and what philosophical examples are,
Nozick was particularly brilliant
at finding the right example
to make his libertarian point.
You know, Walzer was, you
know, one of the people
who very much shaped my view.
You know, there's some
other folks, Marty Peretz,
who also went to Brandeis,
as you noted earlier.
Then, on the practical level,
I learned a lot about computers,
polling, and that sort of thing.
Bill Schneider was one of my teachers
who actually got me into journalism.
So that was a kinda
set of technical skills
that served me well.
My first real job was helping set up
the New York Times CBS polls.
So that's another piece.
And then, the time I
was there was the first
moment when they had opened
up the divinity school
to undergraduates, and I have
always had this interest,
partly, again, we're a creature
from where we come from.
My parents were sort
of seriously religious
and not overly pious, which
is a good combination.
And you know, so I took courses
with Harvey Cox up at the divinity school.
And I always tell students that,
never assume that some
course you wanna take
will be professionally useless.
It turned out that one of the most
professionally useful courses I took
was the one on the transcript
that looks least useful.
It was called Eschatology and Politics.
And Harvey Cox was very engaged
with the liberation
theologians in Latin America.
And sometimes we'd get stuff to read
that was sorta xeroxes
coming up from Chile.
Or it wasn't even xerox
then, it was mimeograph.
And then, you know, some many years later,
here I am covering the Vatican
where the central issue
is liberation theology.
So intellectually, I think those were
sort of, you know, critical experiences.
And then, obviously, a lot of friends.
I still have friends I stay in
touch with from those times.
- Two points emerged when I
read about your background.
One was that, during the Vietnam War,
your default position was always
to get your radical friends
to be able to explain their positions
so the people in your
hometown could understand.
Or at least that was the
argument you made to them.
And then the other was
that your dissertation
as a Rhodes Scholar was really on
what liberalism got right in
the Civil Rights Movement,
but what it didn't get right
and the impact it had on American policy.
Talk about those themes,
'cause they're kinda themes that run
through a lot of your work, basically.
- When I look back on
the antiwar movement,
the thing that always bothered me most
was a sense of elitism that the, you know,
that President Nixon and
all the other Republicans
really took advantage of.
And they didn't make it up.
There was, at times, a
contempt for ordinary people.
And here you had privileged kids
sitting around this great university,
and the people fighting the
war were people, you know,
working class whites, African-Americans.
And it just, you know, it pained me
because this sense of, you know,
average people was not the sense
I knew to be true from my own experience.
And so, I enjoyed taking,
as I said earlier,
I enjoyed having kids
come down to Fall River
because then these folks
are no longer an abstraction
where either you glorify
them in some Marxist theory
or you dump on them as kind of
bigoted or ignorant or something.
And that's not, you know,
all people are complicated,
but there's a lot more wisdom there.
And it was out of that that I,
I was also interested in the
race issue and, you know,
the thesis is, it compares Britain
and the United States on the race issue.
And I always thought
that there was a problem
with theories that, again,
there's sort of an Archie
Bunker view of history
that says, you know,
the white working class
is always hostile to African-Americans,
there is an enlightened white
elite that's very tolerant.
And to me, the real story was that,
you know, working class,
low middle class whites
were usually the people who were in direct
conflict with African-Americans.
And a lot of these conflicts were not
because someone was an evil racist,
it was because there was
a real conflict situation
that wealthier people
could buy their way out of.
And what I talked about in the thesis is,
you know, how this played out in politics.
I've always been interested
in the idea of community.
Probably my favorite conservative
political philosopher
is a man called Robert
Nisbet who wrote a book
called The Quest for
Community back in the '50s.
- And his book was adopted
by radicals, actually.
- It's a fascinating, actually,
I got to meet Nisbet once and he told me
that he hated the New
Left, and yet he said
the New Left brought his
book back into print.
And he always had the
honesty to acknowledge that.
And the community, I thought,
was not just some abstraction,
it's a resource that people can draw on,
and that, when we talked about conflicts
over integration, I thought these were
real conflicts over turf and over
control of something
tangible and valuable,
so that we shouldn't have been
as shocked as we were when there were
conflicts over busing or conflicts over,
or blockbusting where, in effect,
both whites and blacks were exploited
when whites were scared
out of the neighborhoods
when African-Americans tried to move in.
And so, I thought we could
do better on civil rights
if we had a more nuanced sense
of what these conflicts were about
for the people who were involved in them.
- Now your first book,
well we should say, you became a reporter,
you were at the New York Times,
you had assignments in
different places in Europe,
and then you also covered local politics
and after a decade you
joined the Washington Post.
- Right.
- And your first book was
Why Americans Hate Politics,
and in some ways, it really addresses
some of the things that
we've touched upon,
namely, that ideas have consequences,
but that, in American politics,
things had gone wrong because people,
two different groups, the
liberals and conservatives,
were really frozen in their
notions about the other sides.
Talk a little about that.
- That was a fun book to do
because it allowed me to kinda go back
and look at some history
that I had cared about.
And so I was trying to think about,
you know, this was written in the middle
of the first Bush
Administration, and you know,
a sense of what had gone wrong on the left
and what had gone wrong
on the right to produce
the kind of impasse it seemed
we were in at that time.
But the core argument of the book is that
politics in America was cast
as a series of false choices,
and that, you know, we argued, say,
about whether feminism was a good thing
or family was a good thing.
In fact, most Americans think
equality between men and
women is a good thing
and that the family is a good thing
and that that wasn't a very constructive
or helpful way to talk about the problem.
And you could go through
a whole series of issues.
You know, government is
good or government is bad.
Well, in fact, government can be both.
And so there was a, you know,
there was a kind of argument
that was not productive..
I think Clinton took
advantage of that argument.
He ended up quoting the book quite a lot,
which was actually both wonderful
and embarrassing to a reporter
who was covering the campaign.
You know, I suppose in
the end I was happier
that he quoted it than ignored it,
but it was a fun, it was a
very interesting period for me
because I wasn't yet, excuse me,
I wasn't yet a columnist,
so I was actually
trying to cover this fair and square.
And I think I did that.
You know, people can look
at the stuff and judge.
But anyway, it was a fascinating period
and I think he and a
number of other politicians
sorta grabbed the idea that you had to
get out of this argument
into something else,
and that that's what the
country was looking for.
Oddly, Ross Perot had some
of that sense too, in 1992.
There were a lot of, apparently, I'm told,
a lot of Perot supporters bought
my book also at that time.
- In looking at some of your writings,
I saw two among other insights,
but I just wanted to focus on two.
In describing this gridlock,
on the one hand, ideas
were, you emphasize again
that ideas are important,
but they have consequences.
And you look at the ideas
of the conservatives and the liberals.
But in some ways the ideas become sticky.
People don't wanna move
beyond where they are
and empathize, as you said earlier,
Lash talked about getting in
the mind of the other side.
So in a way they needed a
little of your old hometown
in the national debate, in the sense
of actually listening to the other side
to see what could be learned
from the other side so that you could
get a common position
that elevated things.
- I think you put that
better than I could've.
At the end of the 2000 election,
I went to a little town
called Gallipolis, Ohio,
which is in the Ohio River Valley
right over the border from West Virginia.
And I spent the day there wandering around
and there was a, one of my
favorite stories out of that
was, I visited the two party headquarters,
which were on, they were both
facing this lovely square
and looking out into the Ohio River.
And I discovered that,
from the guy running
the Democratic headquarters,
that somebody in town
had tried and tried and
tried to get through
to the Republican headquarters and failed,
so they called the Democratic headquarters
and said, could you get this message
up the street to the
Republican headquarters?
And they did, and they, you know,
and so the connection was made.
It wasn't the case that,
because that happened,
the guy at the Republican headquarters
agreed with the guy at the
Democratic headquarters.
They disagreed fundamentally
on a lot of things.
It just meant that they were neighbors.
In the kind of politics that's
practiced through the mass media,
people aren't neighbors,
people don't know each other.
It's very easy to say truly nasty things
about somebody you have never met.
I mean, once in a while it's easy
to say nasty things about
someone you've actually met,
but it's much harder, and I think,
you know, you're seeing that in many
different levels of politics.
In Congress these days,
people are spending
less time in Washington,
more time in their districts.
People don't know each other's families.
And again, it's easier, if your little kid
plays soccer or baseball with
somebody else's little kid,
your personal attitude toward
the person is different.
Now that doesn't mean you don't disagree.
It doesn't mean you don't fight like crazy
for something you care about.
But it does change the
nature of the relationship
with the person and the
nature of the argument.
And in terms of these, well go ahead.
- No go head, did you want
- No, what I was gonna say,
I was trying to sort of
get to the question
about, I like that notion
of the stickiness of ideas, and, you know,
when is flexibility a violation
of your own principles
and when is flexibility important?
And I think that, you know,
there were certain ideas
at the time, you know,
people who were right
about civil rights couldn't come to terms
with why downscale whites might have
certain grievances that were
more than just resentments.
People who were feminists
couldn't understand
that the strength of the other side's
commitment to family and vice versa,
that people would use it on the right,
you know, feminists were demonized as if
they were proposing that all children
be herded into sort of collective care
for 15 years of their lives.
I mean people, it was a
parody of the actual position,
and that happens a lot in politics.
- Another example which
actually broadens this a little,
you used in something I read
the example of the Bush campaign,
the first president Bush,
in his campaign against Michael Dukakis
on the issue of the pledge of
allegiance in the classroom,
and the extent to which their,
at one level it was kind of malicious,
this whole discussion,
but on another level,
the slogans and the short
version of the story really,
underneath it, lay a real
conflict about values.
And that we were avoiding
getting into the discussion
about one group's concern
about their values
and the erosion of those values.
Talk a little about that.
- Well I thought the '88 campaign
should have taught those
of us in journalism
a lot of lessons, because,
the pledge, I thought,
was an interesting example
because, at one level,
it was a phony issue,
Dukakis' interpretation
of what free speech meant
for Jehovah's Witnesses, you know,
Jehovah's Witnesses had
originally brought this case
- And he signed legislation,
essentially, that banned
- He vetoed a bill that required
the pledge of allegiance on the grounds
that you couldn't force people
like Jehovah's Witnesses,
who conscientiously objected to that,
to recite it in school.
And of course, the shorthand was
Dukakis vetoed the pledge of allegiance.
And actually, oddly, it
was a story I ended up,
in quotes, breaking, because Newt Gingrich
called me one day and said, hey,
I've got this veto message
you should look at.
And what was fascinating was
the Dukakis did not take it seriously,
thought it was kind of a joke issue.
What I thought the press
should have done with that
is said, okay, there is a side to this
that is a kind of, this is
sort of exploitation politics,
but what was Bush getting at?
What Bush was getting at is that
a lot of parents worried
about the messages
that their kids were getting in schools,
and they wanted their kids not only
to learn to read, write, and count,
but also wanted them to
get a sense of values.
And you know, one of
the values is a kind of,
you know, intelligent patriotism.
I mean the irony is that
the pledge of allegiance
was written by a socialist.
It's actually more a
communitarian document
than it is a right-wing document.
And that if, as reporters, I
think it would have been better
if we had tried to cover that second level
and say, okay, what is Bush
really getting at here?
Why does this issue have
traction with people?
And then we might've told an interesting
story about the country
as well as the campaign.
- And this is an argument,
by the way, that you made,
which is that, in a way,
reporters covering campaigns
should be investigative
reporters of ideas.
Namely, what are the
ideas of the candidates
and what are the long-term,
where do those ideas
come from and what are
the implications of the
ideas in actual politics?
- Right, and it's nice
of you to mention that.
I mean I use that term,
investigative reporting of ideas,
because so much of the political culture
is dominated by scandal these days.
And this is not, this is
said with great respect
for investigative reporters.
We would be in a lot of
trouble if they didn't exist.
So it's not to denigrate them
but rather to raise up that art and to say
we should have investigative
reporting on that side,
but we also need to take more seriously
what candidates actually say.
I mean it's a great irony
that party platforms,
which are always dismissed, turn out to be
very good guides to what
candidates actually do in office.
It is very often the
case that the candidate
does what he or she
says he or she will do,
and when they don't do it it's often
because of circumstance and not because
of some betrayal of principle.
And therefore, if we paid more attention
to what candidates actually said,
we would give readers more of a sense
of what might actually happen.
And then also to look underneath
to what their real commitments are.
I mean, for example, I always thought,
in the 2000 election, that George Bush
was much more candidly
conservative than he was portrayed.
Yes, he was very good at using
soothing, moderate language,
but he didn't lie about where he stood.
He didn't lie about the big tax cut
or the privatization of social security.
And I thought that portraying him
as moderate missed the boat,
and in an odd way, not only was a problem
in terms of how people
perceived the choice,
but also, in a sense,
was disrespectful to him.
I think he was actually a conservative
and made it very clear.
And so, we spend so much time on character
that we forget that what these guys
and women actually believe
has real effect on us later on
when they try to put it into practice.
- And what is the reason
for all the static?
I mean we're obviously not a small town,
that is, the national election,
not like Fall River where you came from.
I mean, what institutionally
do you think is at work
that obfuscates rather than clarifies
what's going on in a campaign.
- Well partly, there's a wonderful book
by a guy called, two academics,
Marty Shefter and Ben Ginsberg,
called Politics by Other Means.
And they argue that what we used to
settle through elections we now settle
through non-democratic mechanisms.
Namely, we go to the courts,
we have newspaper disclosures,
or we have congressional investigations.
Now we've always had those things,
but what they argue is
the terrain of battle has shifted
from trying to win an
argument with the public,
which is a democratic
way to carry out things,
and instead we have this
other kind of politics.
That kind of politics is then reinforced,
I think, by the rise of a certain style
of cable television
which thrives on having
one big story, and the big story is often
more effective when it's a scandal story.
And so, we carry out our,
instead of carrying out arguments,
we basically try to discredit,
completely discredit the
person we're arguing with.
I use the term the politics
of moral annihilation.
That's kind of what we do
in politics these days.
And that oddly is one of the reasons
why I think Clinton survived impeachment,
is because I think that the
public was furious at Clinton,
they thought what he had done
was at best dumb and at worst wrong.
But they did not like the process
through which he was being brought down,
and they didn't like the focus,
you know, the more there was focus on it,
the more there was sympathy for Clinton,
not because people liked what he did
but because they didn't like this process.
- Is the fact that news
and political discussion
is becoming entertainment an issue here
in the sense that it's really not
about elucidating and
educating, but creating a show?
- Entertainment should
never be undervalued.
And I mean, you know, when we look back
to periods in our history where there were
high levels of political participation,
before the turn of the century,
campaigns were mostly entertainment.
We shouldn't romanticize.
I'm often guilty of romanticizing
my home town and small towns,
and there are always problems
in that kind of politics too.
But a lot of it was parades and, you know,
fascinating invective that was amusing,
so I don't denigrate the entertainment,
I wish politics were more
entertaining to people.
I don't think it's so much entertainment
as it is, you know, there's a formula
that people have found is
successful for getting viewers.
You know, these are rather
small audiences on cable shows,
but you don't need a huge
audience to be successful.
So what you're doing is engaging
a certain style of political
junkie on those channels,
and then that begins to
reflect back to the rest
of the coverage on other channels,
and even occasionally into newspapers.
So it's not so much
entertainment that bothers me,
it's a kind of sometimes
almost staged conflict.
And it's the staged
part that's the problem.
- In reading your books and
many of your op ed pieces,
not all of them, but you
know, looking here and there,
I'm struck by two things
that emerge in your writing.
One is a real kind of philosophical basis
for your understanding
of what is at stake.
For example, you just
discussed the 2000 election,
and I think you were
saying that Bush actually
was pretty clear about where
he stood on the big issues.
He's for the individual,
he's for really limiting government,
although not doing away with it.
And the same is probably true of Al Gore.
So on the one hand, one
sees in your writing
this kind of zeroing in on the problem
because of your philosophical
roots, so to say.
But then, on the other
hand, there is a theme,
and you actually said somewhere,
"I think politics is really the essence
"of the democratic
process, but what politics
"ought to be about is solving problems."
And in some way during this period
where we weren't getting at the issues,
we weren't addressing either
one of those, were we?
- I mean, I think you're right that
there's a tension in this view,
maybe even a contradiction in my view.
But it seems to me that,
it's Arthur Schlesinger Junior who said
that politics ought to
be the search for remedy.
And I think when most
people come to politics,
they have orientations.
And actually, I think there is, you know,
every individual is more
philosophically-oriented
than he or she might even think.
Most people have quite
coherent worldviews.
And you see that in polling,
where people actually do
have coherent worldviews,
tend to vote for the candidate
who is closest to that worldview.
I mean the more I've looked at polling
the more I've been impressed
that people get the idea.
They know what they're doing.
But when people look to government,
they tend to have a very
practical view of government.
There's no political science concept
that Americans are operationally liberal
and philosophically conservative.
They're skeptical of government, and yet,
when something goes wrong,
they want it to do something.
Bill Cohen, former senator
and secretary of defense,
once said "Government is the
enemy until you need a friend."
And he was, it was funny,
I quoted him in column once
saying that, and he came up to me
about six or eight months later
and he said, you know,
shouldn't have said that to you,
the Democrats in my state are
using that as their slogan
and their attributing
it to me, which is true.
But I think that's the way people are.
They want government to step in
when there are sort of
large things going wrong
that they believe with reason
cannot be dealt with
simply by individuals,
especially by non-privileged individuals.
And I think the kind of
relentless attack on government,
largely from the right, sort
of discredited that idea.
And yet I still think
that's where Americans were.
And I think you saw that
in the Clinton years
where there was a softening of
the anti-government rhetoric.
And Bush is very interesting in that way
because his rhetoric is quite
sympathetic to government.
And yet his program is actually,
you know, Reaganism redux.
Because the pressure from these tax cuts
is designed to reduce
the size of government,
as a lot of, you know, some
honest conservatives have said.
But the fact that he had
to change the rhetoric
suggests that we moved away some
from the idea of always
demonizing government.
- In both your books, in which, in a way,
you're looking for a progressive solution
to this stalemate, and
after listening to you now,
I would almost call it a progressive
conservative position that you have.
- How so? That's an interesting concept.
- Well I think, in other words,
your emphasis on community, basically.
In other words, that your
notions of social justice
strike me as having a community dimension,
and this strikes me as
going back to your roots.
And I think it enriches what you're saying
'cause it moved you beyond
the purely simple social justice position.
So that's my take on you, is that fair?
- That's very interesting.
I mean, I'm a liberal Catholic
is another way to put this.
Being Catholic was important,
the church was important to us, and a,
you know, I think if you sort of take
what the church says seriously,
what the social teaching says,
you end up being progressive
on social welfare matters,
that is to say, you know, the priority is
on the poor and on the least among us,
and you value community.
And that is, you know, that
is not trivial or abstract.
And so, you know, I'm sure that that
kind of shapes what you have called
a progressive conservatism.
For me, my politics are a combination of
sorta that Catholic tradition,
a sorta Michael Walzer
social democratic tradition,
and then a kinda practical
moderate tradition.
I have affection for a
group that no longer exists,
practically, liberal Republicans,
which is that, okay, we have these,
you know, commitments, these
philosophical commitments,
and then the question becomes
what do you do about it?
How do you get something done?
And so, you know, sometimes I say
my heart's on the left and
my head's more in the center.
But it's, you know, but my
heart is still on that side.
And for me, the struggle in politics
is trying to figure out how to
sorta give practical life
to a set of aspirations
without becoming foolishly utopian.
I mean, another of my
heroes is Reinhold Niebuhr,
you know, sorta Christian
realist, great theologian,
and I think that was what his struggle was
is how can you maintain ideals
and yet be practical about the nature
of human beings and the nature
of the political enterprise.
- And I guess another
ingredient in a lot of your work
is a focus, amidst all of
this morass of politics
and the failure of the ideologies
to move beyond their first position
is a sense of how the lower middle class
and the middle class was hurting,
and that these were, in a way,
the key voters in the politics
of the '80s and the '90s,
and addressing their problems,
especially what they were feeling
because of the impact
of the global economy
and what they saw as the
erosion of moral values.
But on the other hand, they
were hurting economically.
Talk a little about that.
- You know, I think it's a simple fact
that they were the key
to most of the political
transformations that
happened in that period.
They were the Reagan Democrats,
they were the people who
came back to Clinton in '92.
Some of them went to Perot in that period.
And, you know, so that just as,
if you were interested in where
American politics was going,
that was one of the, they were one of
the most important groups
to pay attention to.
So there was on that level,
and then there is on the
level of social justice
and what makes a democracy work.
And we did a pretty
good job, as a country,
from the period after World War II
'til about the mid-'70s,
in creating an economy
that lifted everyone up simultaneously.
When Kennedy said "a rising
tide lifts all boats"
it was actually true,
and you go back and look
and the poor gained as much in income
as the wealthy and the
middle class in that period.
And then, for reasons,
some of them having nothing
to do with politics,
that went haywire after the oil shock.
And so you began to
develop this widening gap.
And, you know, it goes back to,
you know, our founders talked about
needing a kind of mass,
property-owning base,
middle class base to have
an effective democracy,
and I think that is still true.
And if you allow large
inequalities to grow,
you have both injustice
and dangers to democracy.
And so, you know, that's, you know,
that's where a lot of that came from.
And then, you know, the simple fact is,
you know, a lot of those
folks were folks I knew
and had a, you know, I
sometimes write my column,
my column is in my hometown paper,
and I sort of always have
in the back of my head,
what would somebody back in
my hometown think of this?
How would this affect
the folks I grew up with?
And, you know, Fall River
was a working class town
with an upper middle class,
where there was a sense
of linkage between people.
There weren't gated communities.
I mean my dad was a dentist,
so I was hardly a working class kid,
but a lot of my friends
were working class kids
and we didn't, you know,
it took me a long time
to realize how, you know,
that these divisions
actually met something outside
the context of my hometown.
I mean you knew, you were aware,
somebody had more money and
somebody had less money,
but there was more of a
linkage than you see now,
I think, in a lot of places.
I don't know how you recreate that.
That's easier in a small town than it is
in a large metropolitan area.
- In retrospect, I guess you believe
that President Clinton,
though personally flawed,
really transformed our politics,
or at least changed the terms of debate
so we could get onto the problems.
Is that fair and would
you like comment on that?
- I guess that's basically what I think.
I mean, I've guess I've
come to the conclusion
that everything you say about Clinton
is true and so is its opposite.
That you can look at, you know,
did he reform welfare in ways that
might end up endangering the poor?
Yes.
Did he spend more money
on the working poor,
billions and billions of dollars,
which really did help
lift up a lot of people?
That's true too.
Did he, you know, usher in this period
of great sort of capitalist excitement
where everybody seems
obsessed with the market?
Yes.
Did he also reinvigorate government
and get people to accept that,
no, the market all my
itself is not enough?
Yeah, he did that too.
And so, you know, the
conclusion you can draw
is did he move politics to the left? Yes.
Did he move politics to the right? Yes.
For me, Clinton is just such
a great lost opportunity.
I mean I think he did have
the capacity to transform politics.
I think he understood where Americans were
and had, in my view, a reasonable sense
about where we should go.
I didn't agree with everything he did,
but I thought, on balance,
he was trying to move us to a place
where we sort of rejoin this kind of,
if you will, Harry Truman,
Roosevelt tradition
of sort of intelligent use of government
on behalf of problem
solving and social justice.
And he got us part of the way there.
But the scandal really, the
scandals got in the way of,
wasted of a lot of his time, first of all.
He had to use a lot of his intelligence
and energy to get out of trouble
as opposed to getting somewhere.
And they ended up dividing us in ways,
I mean it's another irony of Clinton
that he came in with the idea
of creating a new consensus,
and thanks in part to the scandals,
the country again was very deeply divided.
And you look at the results
of the 2000 election
and we are kinda perfectly
symmetrical halves now, as a country.
- But as a progressive, that part of you,
you fault Clinton for, let's
look at welfare reform.
In the end, he ended
welfare as we knew it,
which you see as an achievement,
but he really didn't deliver
the progressive component of that reform.
- Right, if you compare what he proposed
at the beginning with
what he signed at the end,
they were quite different.
I mean the idea that Clinton
had at the beginning,
which I agreed with, was,
that the government policy should be
more pro-work than it had been.
There should be incentives for people
to move off welfare, to work.
It made sense to have
some kind of time limits
to see if you could move
people into the workforce.
But that had to be matched with
real social supports, because, you know,
some of the people on welfare,
some of the folks on welfare
could be moved relatively easily into work
and would seize the
opportunity if they had it,
but there are other folks on welfare
who have very serious personal problems,
and we shouldn't sort of,
I think, in a way, during
the welfare debate,
neither the left nor the
right wanted to acknowledge
that some share of that population was,
there were drug problems,
there were alcohol problems,
family breakup problems, and
that we shouldn't pretend
that those folks didn't need a lot of help
if they're gonna get from here to there.
And what I objected to in the end,
to the welfare bill, was
that, if you were gonna
trade off radical change
in the welfare system,
part of the trade off should have been
that you would put more support in
to help people move from here to there.
Now we were lucky so far, as a country.
Low unemployment does wonderful things.
And people at the bottom have more
bargaining power when labor is scarce.
And so, the welfare
bill have worked better
than I thought it would
in this good climate.
And I think the long-term test,
I think now you're gonna
see some real problems.
The notion that there's a lifetime limit
on people on welfare, what if
there is a terrible recession?
What happens to the person
who hit the five year limit
and has no money with
which to feed their kids?
What are we gonna do about that?
Are we gonna say sorry,
you've hit your limit.
That was parts of the welfare bill
I thought were both wrong and impractical.
- Let's talk about your work as a writer.
In one sense, as a columnist
for the Washington Post
who writes with, I must say, a lucidity,
but a simple statement of the problem
linked to real people's lives,
I get the sense that a column for you
is a form of participation
in a national conversation
not unlike the conversation
you had in your hometown.
- I sometimes jokes that, you know,
for better or worse I was kinda trained
from a young age for this kind of work.
And it's true, I think a column,
you know, I think different
columns do different things.
I mean I do think, over time,
you develop a sense of
who your readers are,
what they're looking for,
and I think it's an interesting problem
for columnists because, you know,
you discover over time,
because nice people write you letters,
that you're speaking through
some group of people,
that some set of people
come to identify with you.
Mary McGrory, again, to cite her,
said sometimes she thought she was
writing columns in certain periods
to make certain people feel better.
You know, because they felt better
knowing somebody had some
view similar to theirs.
And that's good, but it's, again,
that's not sufficient because sometimes
you wanna challenge people,
you don't wanna be entirely predictable,
you don't wanna become a prisoner
of the very kind of predictable ideology
that I criticized in my earlier books.
So sometimes you wanna challenge
even the people who agree with you.
So that's one tension.
I think another tension is
how can you be tough and
unequivocal and also reasonable?
And that, you know, I don't like,
you know, endless sorta
harsh personal attacks,
and yet, I don't like, you know,
a sorta tonally wishy washy columnist.
When you're a columnist as
opposed to a newspaper reporter,
you're there to present
a strong point of view.
And I think for me it's been a struggle,
as I've been doing this now
for I guess almost eight years,
there is the old journalist side of me
that was, you gotta be fair to both sides.
This is a different enterprise.
And so I've been trying to
learn, how can I sort of,
and I'm sure I've executed
this very imperfectly,
but how do you maintain the sense of
the facts have to be right,
people who disagree with you
should come to it and at least say,
well he's not distorting what I think
even though he disagrees with it.
How can you do all that kinda thing
and yet still take strong opinions?
For me, the recount, the
Bush-Gore fight in Florida,
I think it'll turn out
to be, for me personally,
an important moment, because
I really did get angry.
I was very unhappy with what happened.
And I actually wrote
in a column once that,
please permit me a personal statement,
I'm surprised at how
angry I am about this.
And, you know, in a way,
I think for me in Florida
is when I sort of fully accepted
that I was, you know, a columnist,
still trying to tell the truth,
still trying to elucidate the argument,
but that there was a time when you
simply had to sorta say
I believe this is true and
I'm gonna fight for it.
- We had Conor Cruise O'Brien here
and we talked about this
dichotomy between rationale and passion.
And he said, "You have to
think about the issues,
"but the feelings proceed the thought,
"and then of course are
qualified by the thought."
Does that kind of process go on
in your mind in that
way or a different way?
- I don't know if I would wanna
pretend to that profundity.
That's a very nice formulation.
In some ways I probably trust reason
more than I trust passion.
And that's probably just sort of
deep inside me in some way.
And I'm sometimes suspicious of passion.
I guess the word I'd like better
than passion might be commitment.
Or it might even be loyalty.
Where you are sort of,
you're concerned about groups of people,
you're concerned about certain traditions,
you're concerned about certain values,
and those inform your use of reason.
And you don't, those commitments,
you pray that those personal
and intellectual and
philosophical commitments
don't get in the way of
your capacity to reason.
And that's probably
also kinda Catholic too.
- Is writing hard for you?
Or do your words flow easily?
- I've always loved writing.
I've never regarded myself and do not
today regard myself as a great writer.
I think I'm a clear writer.
I mean the writing, the essays I'm writing
that I like best are Orwell's essays,
Politics and the English
Language, Why I Write.
Why I Write's very interesting
because Orwell said that
"I wrote best when I
really cared passionately
"about a question, especially
a political question."
I find that writing doesn't
come that difficult,
but there are moments when I sit down
and I'm a sort of inveterate reviser.
I constantly look at a sentence I write,
even after the column is in print,
and I say why didn't I change that word?
Why did I use that clunky phrase?
But as I go along, I mean on,
today, before we got together,
I had to edit a column with my editor,
and, you know, we do this over the phone,
and right 'til the moment
we hang up the phone,
I find myself saying,
changing a word here or there.
So to sort of get the basic idea down,
to get the sort of
sentences that I like down
is not difficult.
But then, for me,
and different people
have different methods,
some people I admire greatly
produce very nearly perfect
sentences the first time around
and never have to touch
them, that's not me.
And the process of revision is fun.
In fact, my son is in a class where
there's a lot of emphasis on writing,
and the teacher asked me to come in
and talk about revision.
And I think what I'm gonna do
is take a passage of Harry Potter
and talk about what that passage
might have looked like
five drafts earlier.
And how do you get from here to there.
So that tends to be the
way I like to write.
The other problem with a column is
how good is your idea on any given day?
And how deep is your well of ideas
on days when nothing obvious hits you?
Do you have some thoughts that,
do you have some thoughts, ideas,
subjects you wanna write about
that carry you on those days?
And that's an interesting challenge.
And people, the good thing about it
is people give you ideas all the time.
Either because they
know you write a column
or because you run into some smart person
who suddenly makes you see the world
in a way you didn't before,
see some event in a different way.
- And I guess you do a lot of talking
with influential people in
Washington on the one hand,
but I get the sense that
you're also talking,
you're out on the, hustling, so to speak,
sort of listening to average people
and what their concerns are
and trying to mediate these two.
- That's a really nice thing to say.
I probably don't do it nearly enough.
I do like to go out in the country.
I mean, in fact, for me personally,
I've traveled somewhat less because
I now have three little kids
and the travel looks a little different
when you have kids.
And it's voluntary, I
like being with them.
But during the campaign I did try,
you know, I try to get
out and around the country
as much as is plausible.
And I do enjoy, you know,
I find it satisfying,
like that little Gallipolis column.
I'm not sure that column had any
sort of profound insights in it at all,
and yet I tremendously enjoyed
just kind of dropping into this community
and sort of listening to the way people
were talking about politics
and the difference between that
and the way we do it in Washington.
I'm not a basher of inside the Beltway.
That is a term used by some people
inside the Beltway to bash
other people inside the Beltway.
So I think it's a phony
distinction to some degree.
But there is some reality about how
a person, whether inside
or outside the Beltway,
who is not a professional,
they talk about politics
over the fence than the way those of us
either in the media or in politics
might talk about the
same set of questions.
- How would you advise students
to prepare for the future if A,
they wanted to either be in politics or,
A be in politics or B
write about politics?
- You know, the joke has been for a while,
if you wanna be in politics,
from the moment you make that decision,
don't do anything controversial
or interesting, let alone amoral.
- [Harry] Clinton proves it.
- Maybe he proves the opposite.
I don't know, I guess I'm,
I sorta like the idea of using
your years in college as a time
to sort of expand what you know
and not as a time to be
narrowly professionally focused.
Obviously, if you're a scientist,
if you wanna be a scientist you need to,
you've got a series of building blocks,
and it wouldn't be bad to have
more scientists in politics.
But, you know, I think that there is,
sometimes people are very
professionally driven.
I think that, especially
in journalism or politics,
you know, knowing a lot
about how to write and speak
and knowing a lot about
history can be much more
helpful than studying the
techniques of this or that.
I have sorta the same view,
I mean I respect journalism schools,
I know a lot of good people at them,
but I like the idea of
journalism schools after college
and to be a sorta generalist
while you're in it.
And then, also, just do the stuff.
I mean one of the beauties of
newspaper writing especially
is anybody can be a newspaper writer,
anybody can learn how to write a sentence.
You know, and you have
opportunities in college papers,
a lot of small towns are very short
of good people to write for newspapers.
You have a lot of
opportunities to do that.
And the other thing is just obvious,
which is have some experiences.
Don't necessarily commit yourself
immediately to a path, do some things,
have some things you can draw on
when you start doing this kinda work.
- One final question, short
answer because of the time.
How do you see problems ahead of the time?
As a writer, it's very clear in your work
that somehow a muse strikes you
and you're grappling
with a problem, in a way,
before ideas about the
problem have reached fruition.
Right now you're working on,
or you have been working on
religious-based organizations,
and I think you were doing that, actually,
before it became a national conversation
in the way it has with
President Bush's new initiative.
Tell us briefly about, what is it?
Is it the reading?
Is it your knowledge of history?
Or is it just keeping informed?
- Well I hope what you said is true.
I mean I was always struck,
Michael Harington, the
great American socialist,
had a book where his, the subtitle was
The History of the Future,
and I have always enjoyed trying to think,
sometimes successfully,
sometimes unsuccessfully,
about how would this time look
if you looked at it in 10 years?
If I were reading a
book about this moment,
what would that book say
about what happened afterward?
And it's just a habit of
mine, for better or worse.
But as I say, some of it is luck
and some of it is just when
something you happen to care about
also happens to become an important issue.
I mean I've been interested in
the faith-based thing for some time.
I don't pretend I saw the huge interest
that now exists in it coming,
and yet it just struck me as natural
that we were, it was very clear
that we were renegotiating
the question of faith and public life,
that it was clear that the religious right
had had an effect in making
people think about this,
but also that there was a kind of
revival among moderate and
progressive religious people,
an intellectual revival
and a revival of activism.
And I think you could see that out there,
and then the rest has
happened more quickly
because of Bush's election.
- Well E.J., thank you very much
for this fascinating conversation
about your career and why
ideas have really mattered
and why they matter in politics.
- Thank you very much.
- Thank you.
And thank you very much for joining us
for this conversation with history.